hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar optimizing weighing and moisture
determination workflows in the chemical
laboratory
i am kaylee block of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by sartorius
to learn more please visit sartorius.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits i'd now like to
welcome our speakers
celadonio signs
regional business manager asia pacific
at sartorius and wallace harvey regional
business manager north america at
sartorius celedonio and wallace you may
now begin your presentation
great
thanks for the introduction good morning
good afternoon hi and welcome you
to this webinar
we would like to
take some time
to share key concepts about how to
optimize weighing and moisture
determination in the chemical lab
also to highlight best practices for
each procedure well
let's start by looking about the general
weighings
side about the importance of regular
calibration and qualification
then requirements for weighing in
regulated environments and then moving
on to some tips and tricks for
optimizing moisture analysis
the role of sample preparation in
achieving optimal moisture content
results and finally at the end
we will have some time for questions and
hopefully
we got time for all the answers to you
as well
so
let's look first
on the two main reasons to monitor
alabamans
the first one
is about working with defined tolerance
limits
this means that
when we
have certain limits
according to normativity or regulations
or our internal operating procedures the
balance or the
the in this case
the equipment should be
inside these tolerances
and the second one avoid weighing errors
caused by influences from environmental
conditions
such as
the airflow
vibrations and so on and users
or the sample itself or the vessels that
contains the sample
the key concept of
precision and accuracy involves
two main
aspects
the first one is the trueness
about what we want to measure
and
if this measurement tend to the center
of
the actual value
and the position
that tends to to be close together or
spread apart
so in this axis we can see
trueness
in the
y-axis and precision in the x-axis
and the back the best practice will be
to have high position and high trainers
and this is when we can improve accuracy
and decrease our uncertainty
as you can see here the dots
improved from
zero or less
trueness and zero or less position
up to the maximum one
when there are all the dots together so
we can define that accuracy is related
to both a combination of trueness and
precision
and accuracy is affected
by the environmental conditions all the
aspects around the measurement
let me start
with the the balance specifications
the key concepts here are
reproducibility or repeatability
linearity error of center load error and
routing error
the first three of them
can be also seen
in general metrology right
so when when we have the legal metrology
in one side related to the world trade
organization or oml
or legal for trade instruments we we
talk about maximum tolerated errors
and the the instrument will be
tested
for
maximum tolerated errors
as a legal verification and this is
according to iso 17020.
when we talk about scientific metrology
and and the relationship between the
result and the deviation and the
uncertainty
we are calling this certified
calibration related to iso 17025
when we talk about normative metrology
like
the metrology that you can find
in
in according to a norm in certain
industries
we can see that this metrology uses one
or two of these balance specifications
for example the usd chapter 40 or the
european pharmacopoeia
2.1.7
talks about reproducibility
repeatability and linearity error
and the last one of the metrology's
industrial methodology is a combination
of the previous ones so all of them
calls these balance specifications and
that's why these tests are very
important
then we have environmental influences to
the measurement and the behavior of the
balance
such as temperature humidity location
leveling and so on
and this means
everything
that is
affecting the instrument performance
and the last one
effects from samples vessels and users
like fingerprints
like hygroscopic
samples
or magnetic effects and these are
these are the the factors that affects
the sample behavior while weighing
by testing the accuracy we can find
this concept of reproducibility or
repeatability test
in a simple way as the standard
deviation of the instrument
and can be calculated with 10
measurements and the behavior of the
instrument should be something unlike
this
standard deviation curve where we
expect to have
97 of the results inside this
section of
the the arrows below
then a 95.4 percent will be in this
section
according to
more or less two sigma
and in one sigma we can expect
68.3 percent of the results
so the instrument will react or will
show
it the its
standard deviation by this test
and we can say that this is the most
important specification of a balance
because with this one we are going to
use
several other errors around the balance
and also the normative metrology can
use this one for further calculations
the next one
we can imagine in in this graph the
value displayed
and the
nominal value of the of a weight of a
test weight or the mass that we have
placed in in the weigh-in pen
and
if if we placed 100 grams we expect to
see 100 grams in the display so this
line
is the characteristic
line
of this measurement according to the
test value
if
we have certain deviation of of this
idea line
we can call it um the the linearity or
linearity error
when when we
see
only one curve we can say that this is
the second order a second order error
and when when we see a cut
off of curves
like like a sinus
signal there
we can we can start counting the cuts
and and this will add another order to
this equation so
the the biggest error will be
the distance
in between
this idea line up to the curve
this deviation have has
a big influence on the measurement and
for this one we use a weight set in
order to test from the minimum capacity
up to the maximum capacity and we can
draw the entire curve of
of the balance
also
the balance
uh
is
is an instrument that will receive
uh
the loading in in
the weigh-in pan
but
the system
can expect that
this the this way
will will be
not every time at exactly the center of
the weighing pen so
we call the off center load error to
precisely this deviation in between
the value that we can obtain
by weighing at the center of the loading
pan versus
in this case
each of the corners of a balance it's
not exactly in the corner it's in the in
the center of of this square imaginary
square
of
of the corner
and we are not going to add errors if
this this test
shows
the maximum value of the maximum
deviation
in between the the load in the corner
versus the center
and the last one is the rounding error
this error means that the last digit
sometimes fluctuates or sometimes moves
um in between
the rounding of of the system
what is this for example here we we have
this four
and a change of this digit is not
visible in in from us right
but um
it means that if this one
this one changes
to five could be in in the last decimal
would be
four
three
or two digits so we we don't know
exactly what
what's after this
last digit
so we can say that in a rounding error
could be in this case an error of 0.5
digit
and now moving to the environmental
influencing factors
we have this
small picture
that shows
in
in a general way
this laboratory
and we have here
the the biggest eight or the most common
eight factors that uh affect the
balances or in this case the weighing
procedure
so first we have the opening of doors we
have hustle and bustle when when people
walks
humidity
on stable tables
in imagine that the balance is there and
the winging table is not stable
we have vibrations also
the sunlight that affects directly the
temperature of the instrument
we have open windows that creates this
air draft or airflow to the balance and
we say that the worst one is the air
conditioning system
when it's just above the system the
balance
because it goes directly to it to the
weighing pan and the balance
will will transform this force of the
air into a value of mass that it doesn't
exist in in
in reality when we talk about the sample
so it fluctuates
the the real value of the mass
talking about temperature
we know
that temperature
modifies
the volume of a sample right
so
it also modifies the the the volume of
the balance itself
so when we have this
sudden changes in temperature the
balance also expands and contracts
yeah and the value of the mass is
different so
because of the air buoyancy effect
the balance
and and the sample seems to be or
lighter or heavier
and in this case when it affects the
instrument can affect the electronic
components
our components
have
this
maximum tolerated
range of temperature operation and when
we exceed this population the electronic
systems will
present errors as noises inside
the
could be the digital or analog
transformation
we suggest to maintain stable or
constant the room temperature that will
affect the sample and also the
instrument
avoid
ac exhausts as we saw in the previous
picture
also windows
direct sunlight to the instrument
um also this proximity
to radiant heaters ovens
or or any heat
source
like lamps for example
and also a computer's ventilation fan
can affect directly the instrument
we suggest also to minimize direct
contact with sample or weights with
hands
or or or
we suggest to use always forceps or
three cells
and
minimize using your your high your hands
inside the drop shield because also the
hands
modify the inner
environment of the drop shield
and it causes an additional heat source
of
inside the weighing chamber
well
once
you have your balance installed
and you unplug it from
from the energy source
the balance needs
some time to get stable readings
and here you can see the timing for each
balances according to
the readability for example precision
balances
with readability
below
sorry above
one milligram up to a gram it takes more
or less like 30 minutes
analytical balances the classic balance
in in in any lab with 0.1 milligram of
readability takes more or less four
hours to to have these stable readings
and up to micro balances that needs
uh 24 hours to to have
really stable readings so what we
suggest is do not disconnect the balance
from the power plug
keep it always with energy
but in the standby mode
so during nights the
or after work
or or during any any weekend the balance
is not going to consume that amount of
energy
when when you are actually using the
balance in standby mode the balance
keeps itself
ready just to turn on and use it
so you don't need to have this extra
warm-up time
when
a balance suffered this change in
temperature that we that we talk
from from previous slide
we can also
um
draw
the effect of this drift
with um
the displayed value against
the nominal value of of a weight
and
as as the previous test if we place
100 grams we expect to see 100 grams in
the display and when when
when we change
for example here five celsius degrees we
can see a difference in between the
the value of the mass
and we call this error as
sensitivity or temperature drift
um the in in the data sheet you can find
this drift in parts per million
so
less parts per million means that the
instrument
reacts less to these changes
more parts per million
means that the balance is very sensitive
to these temperature changes
in this case for example we have two
parts per million when when the valence
displayed
0.001 grams in difference against the
nominal value of 100 gram weight
the humidity plays
or or plays
two games in
in a common weighing procedure
when when we don't have humidity is bad
for the sample because it is easy
for samples and vessels
or or containers
to
charge
static electricity
and it's very difficult to ground this
static electricity so the sample keeps
this energy
and it's difficult to ground it to to to
take it away
but when we have these high humidity
conditions it's also bad because
condensation may occur
so the the the balances and
in general the weighing instruments
must have this range of humidity between
45 up to 60 percent of humidity
also
in in calibration labs for weights this
is the range that they use for calibrate
the weight of the mass weight so
it's easier to have or to keep this
traceability
up to the the national standard regional
standard or international standard by
keeping
the conditions of the lab stable
unfortunately
vibrations are common in any lab because
of heavy machinery because the street
outside the the the
lab
because of motors in inside the lab
because of passing planes or or even
earthquakes in in the case of micro and
ultra micro balances earthquakes are are
visible in in the readout of of any any
any weighing procedure so
in order to avoid the impact of these
vibrations what we recommend is to have
a very
strong weighing table that
will
absorb this this shock of of
force
and immediately uh goes away so
avoiding damps and or or
these soft materials that could keep
this force inside is our best
recommendation
the winning table as as i mentioned
as big recommendation would be a very
strong one heavy or or or solid one
because when when we have tables that
bends or or
or
they are placed in in
the wrong place in in a lab for example
um in the middle of the lab also the
floor can bend
so this affects the
the weighing procedure and the readout
of the balance so we recommend to have
the best location of the of the lab for
a balance and this could be a corner of
a room
um
near to a load bearing wall
in the lowest floor level as possible
even sometimes if it's possible in in
basements for for calibration labs
and avoid to place this uh near to high
traffic areas if if the lab can be moved
in into another location away from
streets
we recommend to do so
and frequencies
of of these
vibrations should be avoided if they are
higher than 10 hertz
otherwise we can we can
reach some resonance
cycle of of the materials of a balance
and
this is a high frequency with with with
much power we can really damage
some parts of the instrument
use granny tables
and sartorius balances have excellent
filters for eliminating interferences we
have four filters usually in each
weighing system
and
also we suggest
to
put the balance away from walls
and floors
with with high frequencies
once the balance is already installed
it's common that we need to clean the
balance and remove the balance
in order to also clean
the the base of the weighing table
so or the surface of the table so
we have to always remember that
a leveling inclination can cause these
two components of forces
and the real value of the of the mass
that we
that we are
measuring
it's a component
so in this case we show that
in order to obtain the value of the mass
we have to multiply the display value
against the cosine of the
angle that we have
there
and
as this example shown
we have displayed a wrong value of of
them of the mass so
remember to always keep level the
balance
the center of
of the of the bubble target
and this will help you to always be
precise and accurate
another
issue in with when when you move your
instrument from one location to another
from a point a to b
with a difference of of height
is that the balance
needs
an adjustment because the gravity
in between these two points because of
the height difference
is also different
in this in this example we have here
a difference of 4 meters
13 feet
and this will
present a difference of 0.3 milligrams
and in this calculus is 0.26
rounded it's 0.3 milligrams for
analytical balance it's three divisions
and this is the limit for some
maximum tolerated errors in in
in analytical balances
so with this only four meters we have an
error in
in the readout
and
the the
it's even worse when we
transfer a balance from
different cities
so
higher higher
altitude will
will result on on higher the error of
the balance
so um
a simple adjustment of the balance and
return it to to the true value will help
on
precise and accurate results
thin lines with reduces disturbances
because
some samples that are spilled also
attract in the first case
some dust
yeah and
in in the worst case it also damaged the
material so
for example here stainless steel when
when when we spill some material there
and it's difficult to clean afterwards
and and we need
um to use some other
chemical agents we are going to
damage the surface of the high polished
weighing pen or stainless steel in this
case
after several ones we can see that dust
can be allocated there
and
further cross contamination also can
appear
so we recommend to use an absorbent
absorbent cloth to remove liquids
to be in order to be gentle to to the
stainless steel
doors and weight pan
should be also or can be also
placed in dishwasher
we recommend
to use the top rack
and
never use heavy brushes
or or handheld vacuum to to remove
residuals if it's necessary remove the
weighing pan
and if you can see that
it's it's not possible with these tools
to clean your balance
call
our technical service
to do the proper cleaning of the balance
otherwise
you can really damage the inner system
we have also samples that
interacts with the environment such as
the hydroscopic samples
or those samples
that
evaporates
and in this case
for example hydroscopic will will absorb
moisture or water from the environment
and
the the samples that evaporates will
give moisture to the environment give
will keep water
and
in in that case we suggest that
ever touch a sample with your finger
or their
hands or their fingers
use gloves because in in this case or
anti-magnetic forces forceps because uh
the finger
print
has also this fat
and it fat this fat weights and and it
has a 0.4 milligram
weight
by minimum and this one is also
hygroscopic
so in this case
we can see if you have a container or a
vessel with a lot of fingerprints this
will react more or less as hygroscopic
or or evaporating sample
so please avoid to use bare
fingers or bear or or
bare hands
please wear gloves or forceps to
manipulate your samples
we talked about temperature
and evaporation in the previous slide
and we have a very interesting effect
when we are not weighing at the same
temperature as the environment for
example
if we are weighing
above the
the environmental temperature which
means the sample is warmer
it
it means that the sample
has a different volume than
if it was
on environmental temperature with this
difference of volume
as we mentioned in the past with the air
buoyancy effect the sample seems
during the time that it's cooling
it seems like it's
gaining
some weight right so
as this mentioned
warmer samples appears to be lighter
than they really are
and exactly the opposite effect when we
have cooler samples
it
looks like they are heavier than they
really are because when
when they warm
they are
losing
sorry they are expanding
its volume
and they are
losing some weight
so what we recommend is to be repeatable
to achieve repeatability
um
you can wait at the same
temperature always or
wait
up to the environmental temperature it's
difficult in with some
specific
standard operating procedures
especially when when we expect some
reaction or when we are testing
some
other processes
at that temperature so keep in mind that
this temperature will affect the value
of the of of
of the sample
the value of mass of the sample keep the
record of the temperature if you can
and
the best practice is to wait until the
sample is at the same environmental
temperature
magnetic effects
are
also possible to avoid
if
if you want to or if you need
to
estimate the the
value of the mass of the sample we can
we can use several tricks like
using a hook and weighing below the
balance
and
in this with this trick we are placing
the magnetic field as a way as possible
from the balance because the balance
also has internally another
another
magnet in the coil
what we can see when when when we placed
a magnet in the weighing pan
is that the values are stable but they
are not repeatable and sometimes we can
see a small drift if if the
the
the center of the magnetic field is
exactly at the center of the of the
of of the magnet that we are weighing
so
what we can
do to prevent this is to increase the
distance as i mentioned way in below
or you can perform the magnetization of
the sample
you can use
some other
metals
as
a shield for for the draft
for the weighing pen
before placing it into the drop shield
and also you can use special
antimagnetic way implants
static electricity
affects
the sample and sometimes affects the
vessel of the sample
um when when we have these positive
ions in
surrounding
the the sample or the vessel we can see
that
the the sample
acts as they are
lighter than than they really are or
heavier than they really are when when
they are
when the ions are negative
um
so
the problem is that this can occur
without notice
or
it is because of
the environmental conditions such as
low humidity in your lab
in that case you can rise the humidity
of your lab and
you can see that the sample will ground
easily
so
our best recommendation is to eliminate
this kind of charges so use an ionizer
increase humidity or also use a metal
container or metal foil to detect these
electrostatic charges
now moving to the requirements of
of weighing in regulated environments
we have this
big question about how often do we need
to calibrate our balances
we know that according to the
iso 1725
the balances should be calibrated
on on this established
time
more or less should be once a year
and
this is because we want to minimize the
risk of erroneous measurements and
fulfill the required process
of accuracy at any time
but the real
question
is
about
knowing this deviation of the instrument
so
the timing in between each calibration
could be defined according to the
procedure or also can be defined
by
the instrument
if
if a first calibration
shows high deviation
then you perform an adjustment and
when you verify this adjustment
you can see
an error again and also
with another calibration you see a
deviation again
you need to
increase
the timing in between for each
calibration
in terms of more calibrations to the
instrument in order to keep an eye on it
what we
define as calibration is exactly what
what i said
take care of the deviation and also know
the uncertainty
in order to know the uncertainty we need
um
a certified calibration
a verification
is when when
you test the balance and you said
it pass or fails with calibration you
want to know this deviation it's not
only to know if if
it fails or or passes it's also to know
how much it deviates and when
and with with
how much uncertainty
the adjustment allows you to eliminate
this difference
and
we
suggest that the balance must be
adjusted if temperature changes
because this maintains accuracy of the
balance
and
we
we also recommend to use always external
weights
when
calibrated external weights and when you
use internal calibration
you can you can choose
by by do it
in this case with isocal
by certain amount of time
or when the system feels a certain
deviation of the temperature
here is here you can see an example of
the difference in between internal and
external calibration
we have a target of of value
of the mass value
and when we see some drifts or when the
balance feels distributes
the valid the balance itself calls
the
the inner calibration system and pulls
back the value to the target value
it can happens up and down because
of changes of temperature or
it can happen because we are not using
the bands
so
in general terms we say that compensates
temperature for fluctuations also
changes in humidity
or when you change the balance from
point a to point b location with with
different height or different altitude
and
also it compensates
aging effects if the balance is old
the balance will need
frequent internal calibrations
and external calibrations uses the
external calibration weights
here we have some
pictures of calibration weights
our best suggestion for you
is never touch with your bare hands
or fingers always use forceps
for
balances
we need higher accuracy class of weights
so
gloves are not really recommended with
this high calibration high class of
calibration weights
and the recalibration of weights
there is no written frequency
but as
mentioned in in iso regulation
we suggest
every year
there and if
if after several years
you have no changes of it
um you are doing
a great job with your with your with
your weights
remember that the weight tolerance
are typically categorized by class so i
i mentioned these
high class
weights
and
those are class 0 class 1 from astm or
oml class
e2 f1
class c row and class e1 regularly are
only used by calibration labs
for in order to calibrate e2 and class
1.
so
commonly for
instruments are class 1 and class e2 as
recommended a balance should be
calibrating using a weight
according to its class tolerance right
and
as an example a balance with readability
of 0.01 grams a semi-micro balance may
be calibrated with a weight having known
tolerance of at least
0.009 grams
another practice
is
for for challenging your instrument or
giving a powerful calibration
range
certified calibration
is to identify which is your working
range
this is just these three
test points near to the minimum range
up to the working range and near to the
maximum near to the minimum because
it's closed to
the
readability of the instrument
near to the working range because over
there you can see
the the
deviation of your instrument
according to your common procedure with
your common amount of mass or sample
and near to the maximum because if any
error happens there
this error will mean
a lot of mass and also big loss in costs
when you are using samples
at that limit
typically we know that this working
range is around the 10 or 20 percent of
the maximum
capacity and you can do it regularly or
you can ask also to
your calibration lab
according to the iso 17025
it's possible to challenge your balance
test your balance and calculate the
uncertainty value in your working range
also we recommend to have not only a an
upper
intervention limit or this
maximum tolerated uh error for a balance
when once you are verifying or
performing this standard verification of
your instrument could be every day or
or every week or every month
instead of that we suggest to have a
limit
old warning limit for you to
use your
tools that could be an internal
calibration or an external calibration
and then
an adjustment
so the balance will keep
always
this range
near to the target value
and once we have reached this upper
limit with any measurement
you perform a calibration and if it
doesn't work
you can call directly your technical
service
to perform
some maintenance to the balance or
repair
and
with that we are sure that in your
process
there is no chance to
get
bad results above the intervention limit
or your maximum tolerated limit
and now we are going to turn on moisture
so
well as
the stage is yours
okay thank you very much celedonio
appreciate that um so we're gonna shift
gears a bit here and transition into
talking a little bit about tips and
tricks for optimizing moisture analysis
so
when we talk about moisture analysis i
guess the first question that comes to
mind is you know what is it that we are
actually referring to and
generally speaking you know we talk
about moisture analysis or moisture
determination we're really referring to
all the different variety of methods
that are out there for determining uh
the level of water content
in samples whether it be trace amounts
or high levels and these could be in any
types of samples right so it could be
solids liquids gases what have you so
and it's very critical as we know to do
this because moisture has a big impact
on a variety of different aspects when
it comes to final product but also in
the manufacturing process itself and the
quality control
so what are some examples of different
industries that are doing moisture
analysis
this list is i'm sure obviously much
longer than what you see here but just
to give you a few examples obviously it
really covers a wide gamut anywhere from
plastics and med devices
to things like paints and coatings it's
used very heavily in automotive as well
as food and beverage industry
petrochemical waste water
you you name it pretty much every
industry is doing some sort of analysis
because water is such a critical factor
in terms of like we mentioned before
some of its impact on results finished
product quality manufacturing and so
forth
so kind of transitioning into that you
know what
are some of the reasons for looking at
moisture content why are we actually
doing this why is this important well it
really varies you know depending on
industry and application area but i
would say the primary reasons for this
kind of fall into a few different
categories so
one of the the big reasons for this is
obviously product quality right so
water content moisture can influence
things like taste or the texture if it's
a food product mouth feel
if you're looking at
products that are in the pharmaceutical
or petrochemical
area or even food and beverage obviously
it can impact things like microbial
growth uh shelf life or expiration
dating when it comes to products like
this um also stability and integrity so
you know how the products will last and
how long they will hold up
in addition to things like consistency
so that's a big aspect as well as
customers want to make sure that the
product is the same from
from one time to the next
another key area that's important is
production so when we're talking about
moisture content or water content it can
influence things like product
flow through different types of
equipment or packaging
minimizing things like delays because of
how long it takes to dry a sample due to
the water content can also be a factor
and also throughput and waste
reduction are also
very closely tied to water content
levels as well
to
eliminate problems and issues in these
particular areas
legal is another important aspect
obviously because you know certain
products are going to be required to
meet certain specifications
and this can be definitely tied to their
moisture content so with their label for
it has to match up and this could be you
know whether it's federal state
regulations or local
regulations particularly when it comes
to things like food and chemicals and
waste water
and finally certainly not least cost
right we know that water is a relatively
inexpensive ingredient compared to other
things that may go into the mix but
maximizing the water content or
controlling it accurately
is definitely going to be critical
because you want to verify that they're
going to be within the proper limits
right so that when you're purchasing you
want to make sure that you're getting
the best for your dollar both as a
consumer of the product but also when
you're going to sell it since many
products are sold by weight or by
concentration levels
so i thought first we could do just a
brief overview of some of the different
available methods for water
determination there's quite a few out
there
if we kick it off first with carl fisher
titration we know that that's a very
popular technique used in quite a few
laboratories for water determination
some very good advantages in terms of it
looking for water to the exclusion of
all other types of volatiles but it can
be a little bit expensive sometimes
particularly depending on the type of
equipment you may need to measure
certain types of samples and of course
there are chemicals involved which which
can be considered hazardous
if we kind of shift over to loss on
drying or the vacuum oven method
again this is very often used in testing
for moisture content
sometimes it can be a little time
consuming depending on the moisture
level in the sample and how much sample
you may need but it does have the
advantage of not requiring any hazardous
chemicals
spectrometry is uh is also used in some
occasions uh typically you're looking at
more expensive equipment here to perform
a test like that but it also does
require a certain amount of expertise to
interpret and operate the equipment as
well
and then and finally we have moisture
analyzers right so these are very
commonly used for moisture determination
thermogravimetric technique no hazardous
chemicals involved and typically they're
relatively easy to to operate and
interpret the results from so
these are some of the most common
techniques that are used and we're going
to focus today a little bit primarily on
loss on drying and moisture analyzers in
our discussion
we talk about loss on drying i think one
of the most common uh forms of moisture
analysis it's kind of interesting
because there's quite a bit of aspects
involved there what we're talking about
here primarily when we think about that
concept is really taking an initial
weight of a product and then heating it
for a period of time and then taking a
final weight and then you're determining
the moisture content by taking the
difference between the two weights to
really calculate that amount or
percentage of moisture
now with a traditional oven test you
know this typically requires heating the
sample over
a somewhat longer period of time
sometimes it can be up to even several
hours
at a fixed temperature
and there's different aoac or astm
methods that kind of establish what
these parameters could look like
and typically it's always
sent back to or referenced against a
reference standard or method
to really determine what's the best
length of time to get the optimal
results for different types of samples
oven test results are typically not
available for some length of time
because a lot of time it may take you
know several minutes or even hours to
get results and so oftentimes they're
not the best uh source of resource for
getting you know pretty quick results
especially for moisture analysis in real
time
we have on the other hand rapid loss on
drying moisture analysis
techniques and these typically provide
results in minutes rather than hours
right so the optimal situation there is
that you can use these a lot in the
production process in other areas
because they tend to be faster in terms
of getting results real time and they
have rather user friendly methods of
analysis
when we talk about these rapid
lod methods you know typically what
we're looking at here is
measuring the weight loss but it's not
necessarily specific to just water there
could be potentially other volatiles
involved
besides water because you're only
looking at
the weight loss that's taking place so
if you do raise or lower the temperature
of the analysis or change the sample
size or adjust the endpoint setting you
can get different results with the same
sample so that's why it's very critical
to make sure that you're calibrating or
setting up your rapid methods against a
standard reference method like carl
fisher or like some other techniques
like the oven method and it's very easy
to do and most of this information is
available in the literature
and we can help you with that as well
with with our application support but
primarily you know if you're looking at
these standard reference methods like
carl fisher
or an oven method you can get those
those reference values fairly easily
now the question then becomes well how
exactly do i do that right how do i
adjust a moisture analyzer to match the
reference result right so i can get
accurate values and
appropriate levels determined well
there's primarily three main variables
you're going to look at to do this right
and
this is what we're going to focus on
here what those three variables are the
main ones are the temperature
the sample size
and finally the endpoint setting that
you establish for the particular rapid
lod moisture analyzer with those three
combinations of things it makes it very
easy to
pair up or adjust your
instrument to match the standard
reference method and get accurate
results
a couple other things to consider just
when you're making these sorts of
adjustments is just taking a look at
what sort of accuracy is required for
your particular method how how close to
the true value do you need to make sure
that you get and also how quickly do you
need the result this can also have an
influence on the overall
evaluation and your method sop
development
when you're prepping a sample for a loss
on drying measurements this is a very
critical area of the whole analysis
because it can greatly impact the
accuracy of your test results
and actually the time it takes to get
those results as well
so
typically you know when it comes to
doing this the samples themselves are
going to fall into really one of three
main categories
um liquids paste or solid materials
we're going to talk a little bit about
each one of those and how to get the
best results when you're doing moisture
analysis
so this is a good time to kind of segue
into that you know to talk about the
role that sample preparation actually
has in achieving the optimal
results for moisture content so we'll
kind of segue into that at this point
and like we mentioned you know sample
prep really is critical when it comes to
analyzing samples for loss and drawing
regardless of what type of sample you
have
so
one of the key things to sort of
remember is to really try to make sure
that you homogenize the sample first
before you take any uh of it for
analysis and whether that involves
mixing or stirring or taking multiple
samples from different places within the
vessel that you're obtaining a sample
from or at defined intervals whatever
you can do there to make sure you have a
good cross-section of
the material for analyzing will help you
get more consistent results
secondly making sure you're taking the
samples from a sealed airtight container
so that you're not allowing any of the
sample to be altered or in any way
contaminated by the environment is also
something that's critical and important
as well
finally the storage container itself
should not be too large or too big
because you can have moisture from
within the container actually
interacting with the sample so you want
to keep the size of the container that
the sample was taken from commensurate
with how much sample is actually
contained in that vessel
then finally it's just good to keep in
mind that moisture you know can condense
on the walls of the container that the
sample is kept in so you may need to
consider mixing that back in with the
sample before you take measurement or
just otherwise taking that into account
that that can happen and again that can
be minimized by remembering to keep the
sample container
as
only as big as it needs to be to to
maintain the volume of sample you're
going to be testing and looking at
when it comes to liquid samples um again
we've got some key tips here as well one
of the key things to remember is to
really make sure you keep the sample
isolated from the surrounding
environment so that it's not picking up
or having any potential impact on the
sample itself this is really critical
for liquids because they can like i said
pick up moisture from the atmosphere if
they're you know capable of doing that
or if they're
temperature wise different from what the
surrounding
environment is as well
it's important to sometimes stir or
shake the sample before testing again to
kind of get back to making sure that
it's homogenized properly for the best
results
then most of the time if you are going
to use a filter pan or a filter pad
rather inside the pan
it's very important to
keep in mind that it's good to maybe
make a sandwich if you can between two
filter pads if you have a liquid
especially if you start to notice like a
skin or something like that forming on
the top of a liquid sample
it's good to kind of use that sandwich
method
and then finally or one of the other
things to consider is making sure that
you pipette evenly onto the pad so you
don't have too much sample concentrated
in one particular area you want to try
to keep it as evenly as distributed as
possible so that you get you know really
the best results and then finally but
certainly not least is making sure you
run the analyzer at
the proper standby temperature so that
the sample doesn't lose moisture during
the loading process that's critical as
well you don't want to drive off any
moisture before you actually start
measuring for that
in any way using the instrumentation
now when it comes to solid samples again
there's also some good tips and tricks
to keep in mind and we're going to cover
a few of those as well obviously like
before you want to isolate that sample
and really keep it from interacting with
the environment
another good way it gets back to that
whole concept of homogenizing and making
sure you've got a sample that's even
redistributed in terms of size and so
forth is grinding it if necessary to
improve the accuracy and the
repeatability and the speed of testing
if you look at some of the
illustrations there to the right you can
see that we've got samples there that
are very consistent in terms of their
size and
their
relative to each other which is of
critical importance
again that even distribution within the
sample pan is is going to be critical
for best results as well and that's kind
of illustrated here so you don't want to
have like clumps off to one side or a
concentration in one specific area of
the pan like you see to the right here
but the best is going to be if it's
really even and level and consistent
throughout the weighing pan to get the
best results
and then really you know as a rule of
thumb the last thing to kind of keep in
mind there is the higher the moisture
content
the really the less amount of sample
that you're going to need for a test so
sometimes we tend to err on wanting to
add more sample to get a i think we need
to get a better result but in most cases
that's not always the case especially if
you have a higher levels of moisture
content in the percent range for example
when it comes to
paste or samples that are pasty
again same sort of precautions you know
in terms of isolating from the
surrounding environment
stirring the sample to make sure you can
get the best possible homogeneity and
again using that sandwich technique to
really
improve the accuracy when you're dealing
with certain types of samples to get the
best repeatability as well
so something that looks like what you
see here a very even distribution of the
sample between two filter pads is the
ideal situation that you're looking to
have
when you're looking to test different
types of samples
and certainly uh one of the things we
always like to mention just to have
everyone keep in mind is that you know
we do support uh any customers that are
looking into performing these types of
testing and we realize that it can be a
challenge from time to time optimizing
that methodology so we have an
applications method development team
that works very closely with our
customers and our our field support team
to provide not only trial instruments
for testing in your laboratory but also
customer support around methods
development which we've done for
thousands and thousands of samples so
feel free to give us a call or shout if
you have questions or needs in this area
and we'd be happy to support you as well
with our with our application support
team
other than that you know i just wanted
to make sure everyone is aware that we
do have quite a few um information
available online on our website when it
comes to applications and solutions for
chemical testing environments both for
all types of laboratories and feel free
to check that out at the link here
and again we thank you for your time
today and i would say we're pretty much
finished with this portion of the
presentation and if there's any
questions or comments or things you'd
like to discuss in more detail now would
be the time to maybe dig into that so
thank you very much
and i'll turn it back over to our
moderator
thank you celedonio and wallace for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
all right let's get started
our first question is does the internal
weight from internal calibration have a
calibration certificate
okay um
well
interesting question
um
no it it doesn't has a uh it doesn't
have a calibration certificate in
internally it's it's it's a mass
and
this one has a certain value from from
the factory and
doing by doing the internal tests
the the balance is challenged against um
a proper calibrated
mass
so the the final value of it it's an
internal value just for reference
tested in several
different temperature values so
it's not
it's not considered as a weight per se
because it doesn't follow any any
shape
norm international norm it's it's just
an internal mess
for for this internal calibration
thank you very much for for that
question
thank you all right our next question
asks
when performing calibrations is using
the internal calibration isocal feature
better than using external weights for
calibration
yeah i think i can take that one also
um
when when when you
perform an internal calibration the the
balance will show
the deviation of of this internal
calibration so
by testing the balance against
an external calibration with an external
weight with with also a calibration
certificate
you can also see this deviation right
um in the case that this deviation is is
different right um
as the question mentioned i think that
it goes around that
maybe
is not the the suitable class for for
for this instrument and
it happens often
uh sometimes the the
the the weight that we use
for for challenging or testing the
balances is not a suitable one for for
doing it so so
my best recommendation is
um
you can you can perform this
this
calibrations external calibrations
with um the same class from from your
calibration lab or
just one below right if it's an e2 you
can you can use an e2 or an f1
but usually the balance will be um
will will use internally the reference
with uh
the best class according to to to the
readability of the balance
great thank you celedonia all right
oh go ahead
okay our next question asks when i have
a new or unknown sample to measure for
moisture content what is the best way to
develop a method using a moisture
analyzer without wasting samples
okay i can take that one so
yeah there's a couple different things
you can do there to help with optimizing
that
one of the first things to do would be
to take a look at the
weighing range on the moisture analyzer
that you're working with and also its
readability so
many of the units have different
readability and different capabilities
in terms of how low and how accurately
they can measure sample weights so in
that particular situation
especially if you're working with
limited amounts of sample quantity you
would want to look for a moisture
analyzer that has
better accuracy better readability down
at some of the lower sample weight level
so that would be a help
secondly i would say definitely rely or
consult with our moisture
team because we like i said have tested
tens of thousands of samples so there's
a big chance a good possibility that
we've already measured your type of
sample or something similar to it and we
can help you out with parameters and
suggestions and settings for where to
start so that you don't
waste sample and waste time
and then the third and final one i would
just
recommend is there are some different
types of sample analysis procedures that
you can follow to help with difficult
samples
one particular method that's sometimes
helpful in this case is called the spike
method where if you're not sure of the
moisture content of your starting sample
you know you can spike it with known
quantities of moisture and then look for
the additional
weight or the additional water that
comes off in the form of the sample the
moisture itself combined with the spike
that you added and then you can kind of
determine that way how much moisture is
there so there's a lot of different
techniques and and we can help you with
all of those and and those are just a
few suggestions thanks good question
thank you wallace and i want to send out
one more reminder to our audience to ask
any questions now if they have any
just drop them into that ask a question
box on the far left of your screen we've
got some great questions coming in here
our next one asks how quickly can
moisture analyzers perform an analysis
and still return accurate repeatable
results
that's a good one as well um typically
you know once everything is optimized
you can get results for most samples
within just a few minutes and by that i
mean anywhere from three to ten minutes
or less
it really is just a factor like we said
before of optimizing both the
temperature the amount of sample that is
being used and and the settings on the
instrument so with those three
parameters you can really dial in that
time and get results pretty repeatably
um and in real time with your samples so
it shouldn't take any more than than
just a few minutes once everything is is
optimized
wonderful thank you
our next question here asks
what if i can't wait for the sample to
acclimatize to the environmental
temperature the wing readout is wrong
okay i can take that um
yeah
when when you have
no time to wait because of your
procedure
what we suggest is to
care about these two main factors one is
is the the value of the mass
and the second one is the the
temperature value right so
um
if if you keep this value
again and again and again with with your
as
a standard operating procedure for this
particular
test
you can be you can be highly
repeatability or repeatable and also you
can reach accuracy the value of the mass
you know
will be according to this procedure
right so if you want to to have the real
value of the mass you have to do
uh some calculations with with this
difference in temperature with a small
correction intensity
uh against the the
a common calibration weight
and the the relationship with
its density right it's
it's not that complicated so you can you
can have the value of the mass or you
can wait to to have the the
the accurate results with
environmental temperature also with
the same as your sample
great thank you gentlemen for these
detailed answers looks like we have time
for one more question here and this last
one asks i have to weigh some syringes
and pipettes that are filled with
material they tend to roll around or
move when i try to weigh them directly
on the weighing pan what do you
recommend for weighing samples like
these
okay i can take that one too
yeah we have uh for these cases um
uh sample
weighting pens
uh especially for syringes
and
it with with syringes and and pipettes
uh in in terms of weighing we can also
consider to
to
modify the
say the the parameters of the balance in
order to have a dosing
dosing weighing where each drop
really matters
and so we have this these two
these two solutions right if you want to
weigh
the the the syringe itself
you you can use
an an accessory which is a
syringe weighing pan
or if if you are using syringes and
and pipettes with with
with your procedure
by dosing we have the the the solution
in in our balances for
uh dosing dosing weighing so the balance
will will change itself and will care of
each value of each single drop
dosed in in in the vessel or in in a
vial or whatever
yep
thank you
thank you
all right well i want to thank um
celedonio and wallace again for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor sartorius for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye